and now i'd like to welcome back a
veteran ignite speaker
take it away jason crawford
thank you brady
humanity has had a pretty good run so
far
in the last 200 years world gdp per
capita has increased by almost 14 times
but as they say past performance may not
be indicative of future results
can growth continue
one argument against long-term growth is
that we will run out of resources
malthus worried about running out of
farmland jevons warned that britain
would run out of coal and hubbard called
peak oil
fears of shortages lead to fears of
overpopulation
if resources are static then they have
to be divided into smaller and smaller
shares for more and more people
in the 1960s this led to dire
predictions of famine and depredation
but predictions of catastrophic
shortages virtually never come true
agricultural productivity has grown
faster than malthus realized was
possible and oil production after a
temporary decline recently hit an
all-time high
one reason for this is that predictions
of shortages are based on conservative
estimates from only proven reserves
another is that when a resource really
is running out we transition off of it
as in the 1800s we switched our lighting
from whale oil to kerosene
but the deeper reason is that there's
really no such thing as a natural
resource all resources are artificial
they are a product of technology
and economic growth is ultimately driven
not by material resources but by ideas
in the 20th century the crucial role of
ideas was confirmed by formal economic
models
the economist robert solo was studying
how output per worker increases as we
accumulate capital such as machines and
factories
now what he found was there are
diminishing returns to capital
accumulation alone a single worker who's
given two machines can't be twice as
productive so if technology is static
output per worker soon stops growing
but
technology acts as a multiplier on
productivity
this makes each worker more productive
and creates more headroom for capital
accumulation
so we can have economic growth if and
only if we have technological progress
now how does this happen well another
economist paul romer pointed out the key
feature of ideas in economic terms they
are non-rival
unlike a loaf of bread or a machine an
invention or an equation can be shared
by everyone
now if we double the number of workers
we have and double the machines they use
we will merely double their output which
is the same output per worker but if we
also double the power of technology we
will more than double output making
everyone richer
physical resources have to be divided up
so as the population grows the per
capita stock of resources shrinks but
ideas do not the per capita stock of
ideas is the total stock of ideas
so we won't run out of resources as long
as we keep generating new ideas
but will we run out of ideas
now romer assumed that the technology
multiplier would grow exponentially at a
rate proportional to the number of
researchers
but soon after that another economist
chad jones pointed out that in the 20th
century we have vastly increased r d
while growth rates have been flat or
even declining
and this is evidence that ideas have
been getting harder to find
does this mean some inevitable
stagnation
maybe we've already picked all the
low-hanging fruit
maybe research is like mining for ideas
and the vein is running thin
maybe inventions are like fish in a pond
and the pond is getting fished out
but notice something about all these
metaphors they all treat ideas like
physical resources
and i think it's a mistake to call peak
ideas just as it seems to have always
been a mistake to call peak resources
one reason for this as paul romer
pointed out is that the space of ideas
is combinatorially vast
the number of potential molecular
compounds or the number of possible dna
sequences is astronomical
we have barely begun to explore
and even as ideas get harder to find we
get better at finding them
as the population and the economy grow
we can devote more brains and more
investment to r d and technologies like
spreadsheets or the internet make
researchers more productive
in fact the greatest threat to long-term
economic growth might be the slowdown in
population growth without more brains to
push technology forward progress might
stall
now that's a problem for another time
i've only got five minutes here but note
that in those five minutes we've gone
from worrying about overpopulation to
underpopulation
and that's because we've traded a
scarcity mindset where growth is limited
by resources for an abundance mindset
where it is limited only by our
ingenuity
thank you all and uh thanks to brady and
the long now for this opportunity
thanks jason can you share the idea that
you're most excited about
for future growth oh there's so many um
but you know one of the biggest ones is
longevity if we can solve longevity that
gives us the time to solve many many
other problems
and that would certainly solve the
population problem
it would help yes
all right thank you very much jason